in five four three two one what's going
on you [ __ ] motherless [ __ ] to
another episode of genius brain this is
a highly requested guess you guys have
been bothering me about it for the
longest time here we have director actor
[ __ ] Gump extraordinaire justin chon
yo with your [ __ ] weed socks bro he
sucks yeah did you get that from my from
my store which i don't know anymore but
oh you know you don't own attic anymore
now we sold it uh it's been about close
Cheers
a year now you had two locations though
at its peak we had three we had down
tonight we had gas time San Diego we had
Alhambra and we had a point in park damn
you had three locations yeah how did you
get into that well I was always into
like choosing clothing you know my dad
sold shoes and stuff but uh you know I
just were sick of driving up to like
Melrose at the time in high school was
like Melrose then we finally got like a
few stores down in Costa Mesa but not
really you know but then it was so so
much surf skate it like it was more like
surf skate yeah and at that time those
skate shops in Cary like you know some
of the some of the smaller brands like
that you'd find on Fairfax now yeah
so I decided I think it was 2006 2007 we
were like dude let's open up our own
store in Orange County and that's kind
of how that's kind of how it started and
then um with all like my Nickelodeon
money dude Nickelodeon money that and
and you know some people came together
we uh we opened up or in a park store
first then San Diego and then after was
Alhambra but like clothing business man
I don't know it's hard it's it's too
much inventory and if you don't sell it
like you just have a back lot like just
so much inventory that just sits on the
shelves and yeah you're waiting for
Black Friday to try try to unload mm-hmm
you know in a shoes in particular it
takes what people don't understand is
it takes so much storage space you know
to carry shoes and you have different
colors different sizes different brands
and then Youth women you know adult like
mint and it's man and then you know like
the sizes 8's that sell sell like that
and then you always stuck with like
these outlier sizes that you're gonna
have to unload somehow but that's crazy
that you even got into that type of [ __ ]
I feel like most people when they make
their big money they probably blow it on
a lot of [ __ ]
yeah like I did okay well I think like a
lot of people were wondering
specifically I mean just because I went
through a couple of a Commons stuff they
want to know first of all how you got
into acting hmm right starting from just
what made you go into acting at first I
think there's a lot of the times when
people think about acting now it's you
see a lot more asian-americans now yeah
right then it was back in the day yeah
and those doors were very different yeah
yeah I mean I started acting when there
yeah like you said there's no there were
no asian-american actors yeah at that
time we'd saw Jason Scott Lee and you
know the dragon yeah we saw and then and
then it was gently and Jackie Chan right
as I was starting was of where an
American Pie came out yeah and John Cho
was a MILF guy oh yeah
and he didn't have an accent and he was
just some regular high school kid and in
American Pie which was cool and I was
like oh whoa and then I saw but first so
for me to answer question like I got
into it because I I just enjoyed it I
really loved acting and and I did an
intern I went to USC for business and
after my freshman year I did an
internship in Silicon Valley and I was
like man you know Silicon Valley's
supposed to be for progressive in a as a
business setting but even that felt
restricting you know being in office and
I was like I can't I can't do this for
the rest of my life mm-hm
so I enrolled in like a two-year Meisner
program and I started training and stuff
and I remember this one time we did
early on I had crazy straight stage
fright like I would
every time before I'd perform like I get
really scared and we did this exercise
where it was like an improv where I was
supposed to be you do these things
called domestics and I was you know
talking to an imaginary the one was
arrows like my my grandmother who was
dying
and basically you have to do these as
ifs right and and it was is as if my
grandmother had two minutes to live and
I had to tell her that whatever I wanted
to tell her you know you know like I
miss her or I loved her and I remember I
started acting and my back was to the
class and I just started crying
uncontrollably you know it's like a very
powerful sort of improv and and I
started crying really crazy and and then
I just remember being really embarrassed
yeah because it's curvy we're taught
like you only cry three times your life
when you were born you have a kid yeah
when your parents died right so I was
really embarrassed and I couldn't stop
crying you know and I just like sat
there with my back turned to them away
turned around the whole class like got
up and start clapping I was like whoa
man this is really cool I get to I'm
allowed to be vulnerable and and express
myself and there was so much freedom in
that that I just I just really you know
my whole goal in the beginning was just
if I could just make a living like you
just feed myself I was cool that even if
it meant like I couldn't get married and
couldn't have kids and all that I was
okay with it because I get I was able to
do something I love mm-hmm
so that's I mean that's how I got into
it and then I think naturally you just
get greedy no you you get a little bit
and you taste a little bit and you're
like I want more I want more I want more
and you know I'm naturally sort of a
driven person so in the beginning it was
like I did a bunch of extra work and and
uh you know after that it was like you
know it's one line in a show and then
after that it was like
getting a commercial campaign and then
after that it was and I just really but
you know I'm a case of not like being
discovered I'm not a case of like I'm
really a case of from the bottom up
climbing ladder slowly which was good
which was good and even then I've
probably had a lot of trip ups in terms
of like my own ego or or in terms of
what I thought it was about and kind of
staying true to uh to what's important
you know when you're following like an
artistic endeavor like that you get
blinded by fame and money and and what
you think was you how old were you when
you first hit it off because you said
you were Nickelodeon first right and
that that was show her you wanted
Nickelodeon I was on a show I started
doing Disney stuff first before
Nickelodeon but basically I started when
I was twenty twenty-one around they're
like you're super young when you got
like bigger roles I mean that's yeah big
yeah so like I did Disney first I did a
bunch of Disney pilots like I did I
remember I did a pilot with Vanessa
Hudgens when she was like like ten or
something oh sure she was young you know
and and other kids at in that show like
Moises arias like he's he went on to do
really well and it's funny because like
you have a really funny story I don't
even know if I should tell it but like
but I yeah I did Disney stuff I did a
you know that Disney Channel film with
Brenda song and yeah and then that the
show I was on for for Nickelodeon was
called just Jordan hmm it was a black
show the diversity calls yeah but it was
cool man they were trying to be that's
what's cool about children's television
is that they're a lot more open yeah
like casting against type like I was
actually the captain the basketball team
and all that like dude and I suck at
basketball I look dumb but like they're
open to really challenging stereotypes
on kids television way more so than
mainstream like adult content like I
just feel like as kids too like they
just don't have that pre notion of where
people belong in terms of like their
color race yeah I have a great example
of this like when when I went back to
Sacramento not too long ago I met this
cat is this for
you know do now my whole life I [ __ ] you
[ __ ] out we went to elementary school
together junior high together and we
didn't talk so much during high school
but when I met him ugh
because he he got my number through
somebody else because you're like I
would like to talk to you and just kind
of like pick out your brain because he
was like going through some [ __ ] and he
wanted to figure out what he wanted to
do and he just saw what I was doing and
I was like you know what elementary
school friends why not he was super nice
to me as a kid so let's meet up meet
this dude and he just goes David it's
been so long I haven't seen you in
forever
I'm like dog did you always have a
Filipino accent he goes yeah like I've
always had a Filipino accent I'm like
what I had no [ __ ] idea cuz as a kid
you don't really think about yet things
I had no I thought he was [ __ ] around
with me I was like stop talking like
that he had no I always had this accent
what the [ __ ] are you saying I thought I
was in like some alternate universe yeah
but when you go back at it I'm like
that's right maybe he [ __ ] did
because I knew I knew that he wasn't he
wasn't born here he wasn't he was a
Filipino image when he came here when he
was like five or six but damn he kept an
accent even yeah coming here at six yeah
I mean this accents I mean I'm kind of
exaggerating a bit but yeah it does have
that accent yeah yeah it's like if you
grew up in k-town your whole life you
kind of have that like k-town swagger
you know like you if you grow if you
only hang around a certain group of
people you're going to if you hang
around only Mexicans yeah you had to
have a little bit that flavor oh for
sure it's kinda like that yeah so I just
I was just so [ __ ] shocked I was like
you're [ __ ] with me bro but you are a
straight-up American he goes no I always
have this accent but that just goes to
show as a kid like you don't you don't
really think in those groups until I
feel like an adult or somebody else
tells you about these yeah that thing's
right yeah because you're just playing
for square with the kid you're just
playing wall ball or whatever you know
and most likely you just getting me
funny because you're fat or too skinny
hey yeah yeah yeah so you did the whole
so you did the whole Disney thing and
then when did when did Twilight come in
I was after the Nickelodeon show and
because Twilight must have been the
craziest because Twilight fandom was
[ __ ] insane yeah
your most funny is I thought this one
movie I did was going to be
it was in between seasons for
Nickelodeon and it was called crossing
over and I thought that was it I thought
it was it I was like I was I was
convinced I was famous Yeah right it was
directed by this guy named Wayne Kramer
he directed this movie called the cooler
that got Alec Baldwin an Academy Award
nomination oh [ __ ]
and he just was dope like he was homies
with Tarantino and and and it was a
Weinstein film and I'll tell you a lot
about what might happen afterward but
like Sean Penn Harrison Ford and Ashley
Judd Ray Liotta Alice Eve Jim Sturgess
Josh GAD like the cream late at the top
man yeah and I was a lead of my story
that was kind of crash where everybody
had their own sort of their ethnicity
had their own thing I thought that was
it man but then like the Weinsteins
buried the film and like and then Sean
Penn want to be cut out of it I don't
know I don't know exactly what happened
but it didn't come out for like four
years
yeah years and it would it like I just
you know how I found out came out I saw
it in a DVD bin what the [ __ ] at Target
yeah I was just like damn what was his
phone call the guy crossing over no I
think it's on Netflix I don't know
anyway like you know um but then you
know and then I went back to Nickelodeon
and you know mind you they didn't want
me to do that film because it's like
such adult content you know and then the
writers strike happened so that the
Nickelodeon show come didn't come back
and I was happy to be on that show man
like it was such a great sort of
learning experience and I don't care
what people have to say about children's
television like it's it was it was
liberating fun for me but um but I was
like you know what I I always wanted to
be like a young Asian Sean Penn I took
acting very seriously and so that's the
type of roles I was like gonna hold out
for my agent called me up and is like
hey I want you audition for this film
and I was like what is it and he was
like it's called Twilight I was like
okay what's it about it's about a family
of vampires and a love story I was like
[ __ ] that
all right as I gets based on a book one
guy [ __ ] sparkles like a disco ball
football and you know anyways like but I
was like well who's involved and I just
I was pretty resistant because I was I
really wanted to do some like work that
meant something to me
but she's he said Catherine Hardwicke is
directing and I was like oh my god you
know I love 13 and oh it's a dog town
and and who's the main star Kristen
Stewart night and I just seen her and
into the wild and she was fantastic in
that I'm like okay that's enough reason
for me to do this and I auditioned and
and I got it into Catherine's credit
like she fought for me because they
didn't want me hmm and you know um they
didn't feel like there were any Asians
and in Washington forks Washington so
yeah I'm lucky to have been a part of
that and you know I'm really not in much
of it after the first film but it was
cool you know what it taught me was what
I wanted and what I didn't want because
I saw the main three kind of you know
like from a periphery see what they were
going through with all the fame because
it was crazy Fame you know like for sure
it was Edward :
yeah yeah his real name is Robert
Pattinson okay I didn't really well both
him sound white his [ __ ] okay I
couldn't tell the damn difference he he
blue though oh I'm pretty sure there
wasn't a single place he could go in
silence dude yeah so that was kind of
thing like people would have to like to
go to a dinner he'd have to like there's
an operation man and I was like okay I
don't want that mm-hmm and yeah I don't
like being famous I don't think is all
it's cut out to be and then just seeing
like when the world is your oyster like
that also what matters to you so it just
it did change my perspective on why I
was acting and what it is that I wanted
which was while after that I just really
focused on trying to do a lot of indie
films and and um because don't you feel
like sometimes it's hard for an actor to
try to reinvent themselves when there's
already like a public perception of who
you are and this is who you should be
yeah right because I feel like that
happens to a lot of people who fall into
very highly successful sitcoms
cuz I'm like that yeah cuz even when I
saw Brian Cranston in Breaking Bad right
or any of his films like he's an amazing
[ __ ] actor amazing but watching
Breaking Bad I had trouble looking at
him for the first two episodes because I
remembered him as malcolm in the middle'
yeah dad Yeah right and so I could see
how hard it would be for a lot of actors
to kind of just cuz the public
perception of who you are is very strong
like they almost don't want to see you
in something different besides the stuff
that they love you in yeah right it's
very true and that's the marketing
machine that's the mission that's the
product driven aspect of the industry
that I you know it's necessary it's it's
it's what keeps things alive but but you
know like for the case of someone like
Robert he after the the the films like
he did so many interesting films and I
really respect him for that like I was
just like wow this guy is like a real
actor yeah and you know really didn't do
any studio films and and now he's
playing Batman and I think like that's
all well deserved and it's about time
that he's playing Batman yeah what's the
[ __ ] that's crazy I spent Batman and I
think like he's ready to go back to that
but like he's done so much so many films
they're feeding his artistic soul that
I'm like good on you I'd like now it's
like oh now I'm interested to see how
you do it now
like how you don't kind of black Batman
you're gonna play I mean there's just
this point to where I think a lot of
people don't understand you just gotta
do [ __ ] that you hate sometimes to get
to where you need to be yeah and a lot
of people don't get that they go I just
want to do things that I like always
it's like well good [ __ ] luck yes if
that was the case and I always tell
young people about this too is that you
need to stop trying to satisfy
everything with your career yeah meaning
that you want your career to be the
happiest thing the most soul satisfying
thing make you a [ __ ] ton of money
you'll get fix your family problems
everything can and it doesn't work like
that too and so like people always ask
they go like here's the thing that a lot
of people didn't know when I started
doing YouTube I wanted to quit after the
first year yeah cuz I hated it I [ __ ]
hated YouTube like I [ __ ] hated it
the only reason why I stayed was because
of Barton Joe yeah
Bartow Barton Joe told me to stick with
it and because it was gonna go somewhere
it would
open or the doors which it did but I was
a stand-up comic I like doing stand-up
yeah and then my youtube videos at the
time were failed stand-up comedy bits
that I RiRi worked into three minute
segments
I was really [ __ ] loud because I heard
that people had a short attention span
on YouTube and I wouldn't be able to
tell a story like I do was stand up so I
developed this [ __ ] loud loud
character and I just did it you know and
so for me when I was doing those videos
I'll be it too like I really enjoyed the
fact that people were laughing at it cuz
at the end of the day was standing up I
just want people to laugh and if you
laugh from it made me feel good but for
me I had to relive my broken stand-up
sets and put it into these videos yeah
yeah right so I didn't want to do that
[ __ ] and then it led to other things and
other opportunities because they just
see that you oh you went from here to
here it's like no it's like YouTube was
hard for me like that first year I
wanted to quit you know yeah yeah I mean
I tried it and I was like hell no I
can't do this I was like well I totally
underestimated this I was like no I
could just you know kind of post and
when I want and I'll do something once a
week but like hell no man that [ __ ] is
is a full-time job and and trying it for
a few months I was like this isn't
business for me like it really is a
full-time job and I always tell people
they go oh well I could do YouTube and
this I was like YouTube is something
that you become successful doing
part-time yeah it doesn't work that way
it takes everything out of you yeah and
a lot of younger kids now their dream is
to become a youtuber which [ __ ] blows
my mind yeah and that's like a career
choice now yes for you to want to be a
youtuber and that whole space was such a
such a weird part for a lot of people
but on the other hand too I think a lot
of youtubers don't get the other side of
acting and film because they're so used
to doing everything within their control
and then they don't understand that when
you [ __ ] with other people's money you
have no [ __ ] say yeah it's very true
which was the hardest reason why I
couldn't get auditions and I couldn't
get an agent yeah because they had such
a bad taste from working with youtubers
yeah they would expect the world cuz
they're so used to having everybody say
yes and do whatever they want and so
they would go to these auditions and I'm
not gonna drop any names but [ __ ] you
guys but you guys would go to these
auditions and then you would act as if
the role was already yours just because
of who you were on this
line presents yeah it's like well that's
great [ __ ] four-year-olds watching
they're not gonna watch this film you
[ __ ] dumbass yeah no and they didn't
get the rules like oh they just don't
know what they miss done they know what
they missed out on you suck as a [ __ ]
actor you trash bag
yeah and then I would try to get like
auditions and they're like now he's a
youtuber don't [ __ ] with him yeah and we
did [ __ ] and then it flipped oh yeah
[ __ ] finally you know yeah yeah is that
crazy though like I do feel like it's it
there's such a adjustment period like
for youtubers and the whole YouTube
world coming into mainstream sort of
consciousness and I feel now it's kind
of balanced out like yeah like you can
cross over if you're if you got the
right you know if you have your head on
straight and but also like you know
youtubers are also like considered just
as much celebrities in it as anybody
else oh for sure and they have to
understand too it's like if you're a
youtuber and you go like well I could do
this to the other other well that's just
a different realm and you have to
respect that art for what it is right
yeah so just as the same as they
probably can't do what you do you can't
do what they exactly yeah and I think
that's that's what's funny is like in
this in entertainment everybody tries to
create this hierarchy mm-hmm unscripted
scripted television film indie film like
it's it's all sort of people try to find
a way to like say oh I'm better than you
yeah there's no weird biz which is like
everyone's just creating [ __ ] like like
what's the reason to operate that way
well you know they they like they like
people to be put in their place for some
[ __ ] reason
yeah like I'll never understand that
[ __ ] you know they go well like for
example like I always say if you're if
you're on a YouTube space or if you came
from vine or Instagram don't think that
you being able to take 30 [ __ ] takes
of you reworking a joke and be able to
do that when you're on an improv show oh
hell no good [ __ ] luck you have been
good on that spot yeah I learn how to do
here yes ends and if you don't know how
to do that your [ __ ] fire and he
found out there's like a couple of
people who came up on wild and out not
Tim like Tim killed in a while the now
yeah but there's a couple of youtubers
Asian youtubers that tried coming onto
that stage and I
heard from quite a few people on that
caste they were like they were trash
because they're so used to talking to
Campbell yo what's up blah blah blah
blah and you know talking big but when
you're put on stage in front of people
you have to improv and you have to act
and do your [ __ ] yeah
trash yeah and that's just to say like
you underestimated what other people did
yeah no you looked at that what they did
was easy yeah and it's not
yeah they got rekt the guy that's
[ __ ] great
but you did um you did a second film
that got into Sundance miss purple yeah
but how did you start miss purple so you
know I was hoping to shoot a another
film that I'm actually gonna shoot next
month but I was ready to shoot that last
year and that film is with macro this
company that made you know sorry to
bother you
mud bound and slew of other amazing
films but um I just don't think we were
ready so I was like okay I was also on a
ABC show and it was in between seasons I
didn't know if it would get picked up
for a second teaser or not if it did get
picked up I wouldn't be able to direct
anything for another like year yeah yeah
so I was like [ __ ] man I don't want to
stay out of the director's chair that
long because then I'm gonna get rusty
and you know so uh miss purple was an
idea that I had for years you know I
really wanted to make a story about
siblings specifically like a brother and
sister I just don't see that in film a
lot and I also wanted to tell a story
about you know a family that that are
from k-town you know that is from k-town
and Koreatown now is so gentrified and
it's become such a like a cool place to
live you know that wasn't the case in
the like 90s so you know sometimes I
look at like people who I knew that grew
up there they're kind of like ghosts in
a way because all this stuff is
developed around them but they still
like live in their bubble it's really
weird but I just wanted to tell this
story about people got enough it feels
like they got left behind mm-hmm
and then also like the thought of like
taking care of your parents and and and
the stuff we have to do to you know take
care of them like this main girl she has
stuck around the brother is you know
estranged and the live in hospice nurse
quit so she begs him to come watch the
dad and he does but um what she does for
work is she's a told me you know she she
works at a karaoke and and he's like a
hostess and you know I mean that [ __ ] is
real you know and and I just wanted to
tell on his authentic story about you
know about us and you know I think we
have films like crazy rich Asians and
and black panther and all this stuff but
like specifically crazy rich Asians I
think it's necessary and I think it's
great for us but it is about like the
point zero one percent oh yeah for sure
and I think that most of us don't live
in that type of wealth mm-hmm you know
we kind of most of us are just working
class and if you notice the films that I
make are about you know working-class
folks you know and and uh you know I
think my films I wanted to represent a
lot of us yeah
but yeah you know I just miss purple was
like very very personal and and it's a
type of films that I like to watch yeah
yeah I mean that's the difference just
like you know when when crazy rich
Asians came out people are like are you
hype for it and I told my friend was
like no I'm not it was not my type of
film yeah I just it's just not what I
normally watch here's the thing you're
allowed to say that yeah you know I mean
I still bought a ticket ya know to
support it I know what it's good for
yeah they're like did you go watch it
immediately I was like no I didn't have
the time so I just bought a ticket yeah
exactly you know so I bought the ticket
and then I watched it later right yeah
and they're like well what did you think
about the film I'll say it wasn't my
type of film yeah I knew right off the
bat that I wasn't gonna vibe with it
because I can't relate to it so that's
that's just what it is and that's why we
need to get to where where we do have
films that sort of cater to all of us
yeah right so like if crazier rotations
is your type of film cool no an hour oh
now we have the farewell we have you
know my film
you know there's a lot of different
films that we can make that isn't just
one monolith isn't just one type of film
for all of us he doesn't make any sense
we're all so different
yeah like the type of [ __ ] we're into
you know that always bugs me it's like
you're not allowed to say anything bad
you know have you seen as eases new
stand-up I'm all set it's pretty good
you know he talks about like obviously
he talks about his everything that
happened with the me to thing but then
also he talks about crazy rich Asians
pretty [ __ ] funny I should watch
because it's just like he's talked about
how white people like it's like we
guilted them into into like you know be
nice to us and he's like yeah it's nice
but but I do feel like we're living in a
time where we're I shouldn't have to
blot blindly follow something because
you know it's it's it's people are
telling me to yeah you know I I do think
you're right we should buy the tickets
because we don't have enough here's the
thing right now we don't have enough to
say you know to be like I'll [ __ ] that
film you know we don't have enough films
for us so every time I film does come
out that's for us by us we need to
support it now when we get a little bit
more sophisticated like the
african-american community has like now
they can make it get out now they can
make all these different types of
african-american films you know and it's
sustainable but right now we're not
there yet so I also get like why we need
to support we have to yeah that's why I
like I said I just bought the ticket
yeah and I was like cool I know what
this is going for but the ticket and
then I moved on and then people are like
well why didn't you like it I was like
well here's a thing to like film is art
right so art can be appreciated
however they I want to interpret it yeah
if I don't like it I'm allowed not to
[ __ ] like it yeah I don't the like
because you tell me to [ __ ] like
exactly you know I didn't like there's a
lot of films that you probably dislike
that I [ __ ] love yeah and it's so I
know what the purpose of where the money
goes to like completely get that yeah
but there shouldn't be a conversation
where you get upset at me for not liking
a film because you feel like it's gonna
have some kind of like crazy great way
for us it's like yeah I support that
yeah I just don't like it let me let me
not like it it's not like when some of
my friends are like yeah I didn't really
think your film
was that Graham like who whatever yeah
it's all good it's a black-and-white
film you're all so stupid so it doesn't
matter you know so it's it's it's you
know tastes and preferences allowed but
you know people tend to be a little more
sensitive about stuff like that nowadays
so it's like I don't even know where to
begin and start because I always tell
people that I found a lot of even people
that I know personally they are the
loudest [ __ ] people like on Twitter
on Instagram about Asian representation
but like that's funny because two years
ago you weren't saying [ __ ] yeah you
know you were not there and when I was
struggling with it you couldn't even
relate you're just like oh I don't know
what you're talking about and now it's
just like oh man we need more Asian
representation you shut your [ __ ] ass
up dude you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
hate that [ __ ] dude yeah I don't know
it's it's I I do like it though
you know people we do want to see I
understand I can't relate to this but I
can't understand why people want to see
familiar faces on the screen right and I
think I just grew a blessing a very
diverse area yeah so I never thought
about racial things too much yeah right
so it's like like we had a conversation
with somebody about Asian superheroes
maybe they're like oh why can't [ __ ]
Superman be Asian and I just straight up
said I was like because I wouldn't watch
that [ __ ] they're like why I was like
because I never looked at Superman and
said oh man I wish I was a white guy I
just wanted to be a alien Mehcad bus bus
through walls
yeah like the race thing didn't click in
my head yeah I never looked at Superman
and said I couldn't be him because he
was white yeah I'm gonna make me want to
be white yeah I just wanted to be a dude
that could bust through [ __ ] and fly
really fast Yeah right so maybe my purse
maybe that's just not how I saw things
but I feel like a lot of people had that
chip on their shoulder yeah yeah people
do man and um for me what's more
important right now and I talk about
this a lot but like you know in the age
of black panther miss Paula and crazy
rich Asians that's cool we need that you
need we need that but what I'm
interested in the film and the
storytelling that I'm doing is how we
coexist you know how you know so Miss
purple has a whole Chicano storyline
that weaves to the film and if you
notice like the score a lot of its is a
you know mexican-inspired and and what
interests me is how we live in the
United States together yeah not like on
our own corners of of the nation like
it's like no no like let's show it for
what it is you know like how do we how
do we how do we how are we in the same
space you know I don't see that very
very much and if they do a lot of times
it's to fill a quota the check marks
like oh yeah we need one Asian guy black
guy that's not helpful either
yeah people's reality is only based on
where they live like I think I I read a
couple of reviews for when kook came out
and I think there was only one review
that bothered me a lot I mean there were
some people that just didn't like
certain things about which is completely
everybody yeah but there was one [ __ ]
review that got my ass and it was just I
got so [ __ ] irritated because they
wrote that they're like they said that
the Hispanic characters weren't real and
I was like you [ __ ] kidding me guys a
[ __ ] bottom that's him nobody told
him to act that way yes that was just
him yeah and he was like Mexican people
don't act that way it's basically
they're saying I'm like Doug did you
grow up in East LA yeah have you been to
East LA what they don't know is those
aren't actors exactly people weren't
actors I got I got like that's what's
crazy is like I got real people yeah
from the hood yeah right those people
like I made a concerted effort to find
real people to fill those roles mm-hmm
so it was authentic so you couldn't tell
me it wasn't real yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying that's why that review it got
my ass I was like I said that was it a
was it a white purse of course you know
I forgot what the [ __ ] do they know
about like about being a hood yeah and I
was like you didn't grow up in East LA
dude and like ah the Hoos I forgot his
name no but he was [ __ ] dope it was
the the guy that you gotta stack that
the main dude the main that the main
Mexican cat for what for [ __ ] what's his
name Mexican dude another one that puts
you up against the fence oh oh I'm Cesar
yeah Cesar do Cesar was so [ __ ] dope
but they were like talking about him I
was like Cesar of all people he's that's
who he is that's what I'm saying so I'm
like how the [ __ ] do you know why I mean
like he's reformed of course you know
he's not that he's
like an actor like a real actor yeah
he's a real actor but like he comes from
that yeah that's that's where he came
from something that's why should it age
me I was like kind of that was the only
female females like how [ __ ] dare you
like yes you can't talk about it not
then the authenticity of something from
something that you've never experienced
saw lived breathed or even have been
there yeah so what the [ __ ] are you
talking about dude just like dude that's
so irresponsible like I just want to
slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] out that guy yeah
I feel like those reviews a lot of times
you have to say something that someone
else hasn't said or be controversial or
like because otherwise their opinion has
no value I think there should be a rule
for films too it's like you don't get to
write a review for a film until you sat
with it for a couple of days yeah
because like even like on Sundance you
know those films that we were watching
yeah there was a review for like two
hours after it premiered I was like how
can you judge a film after you there's
no [ __ ] way I yeah there's no [ __ ]
you haven't really thought it through
yeah like yeah that means you saw it you
walked outside and you started typing it
on your phone yeah yeah what the [ __ ]
man like you could at least like sat
with it watched it again and then
reviewed it because that's what happens
to a lot of just like digital media
because you have to be the first cuz
things come out so fast yeah especially
with music that's how it is with music
yeah when an album drops people are like
yo the best album of all time how it
just came out yesterday yeah I think you
can say of all time that's like you know
I mean even like the best out the true
best albums of all time it's taken
decades to really sit on it and really
evaluate why it's the best album of all
time yeah when people used to do like
music reviews man like you were supposed
to sit with it so because it's a
discography yeah
it from track one all the way to track
12 or whatever yeah there's a flow
there's a reason why they chose these
tracks to line up the way that they did
yeah if you have a sat down and listened
to every [ __ ] track without skipping
through it you shouldn't be able to
write a judgement piece on it you didn't
get to sit with it yeah like that's cuz
I used to do that [ __ ] right it was like
a John Legend that came out it was
revolver right or evolve a revolt
revolver I think but I [ __ ] when I
first listened to it I this just sucks
uh-huh and I hated it right and I just
kind of wrote it off and then one of my
boys were like oh yeah I was actually
pretty dope like it's just go back to
listen to it again so I just said [ __ ]
it stayed in my
room blasted it listen through it and I
was like yep this is a good album cuz I
was just so dismissive of me as it
wasn't like his older stuff yeah so you
know I don't understand how people can
do that with films like even with the
film like the last black man in San
Francisco right mm-hmm
I mean when I watched it I couldn't even
make a head of what I just watched right
yeah so very unique film yeah so people
were like what did you think about us
like I don't have an opinion yet yeah
let me go back and watch it again
because it's so nuanced it's such a
[ __ ] nuanced film yeah like I
couldn't number one like it if you guys
haven't watched the film you should
watch it because it's so it's just
beautiful right very beautiful the the
thing I love about the film the most
right off the bat was a score yeah I was
like wow this is [ __ ] amazing because
it because I feel like even the way they
directed the acting or just like the
direction and just how it was it it
plays like a theater like like a
theatrical uh like the actual act I was
like oh this is so [ __ ] weird so I
have to go back and watch it but I'm not
gonna happen opinion on yet until I sit
with it yeah cuz I don't know I think
that's very insightful of you man I
think I think it should be that way and
um you know I find myself in the same
trap you know like judging it right away
and dismissing things but there's a lot
of films that have like really bad
ratings that I love you know but um it
takes me a second you know and also
there's films that I love that I watch
over like that i watch over and over and
I realized they're even better than I
thought mmm the more times I watch it
you know um yeah like any of the Mexican
directors like the interviews or the
quad owns and stuff every time we watch
I've got all I pick up something new and
there's stuff that like they put in
there and on purpose yeah it's not an
accident and I'm like oh my god I did
how could I and I can never unsee it I'm
like how did I not see that before I
don't know I think great films are meant
to be watched more than once yeah and
people have such short attention spans
that they just want a new thing yeah
it's like you know when you're watching
porn and [ __ ] yeah it's like dude if you
just if you just spend your time with
one video like one good good video you
probably enjoy more than but then like
you're so focused on like trying to try
date
the the the best the best video the best
clip whatever and then you're like it's
like two hours later an hour later
you're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] sucks
porzel your space though yeah corners
like one of those things is like I
always find it weird when I when a
couple of my guy friends are just like
you know do you know this pornstar else
I bro the fact that you even know their
names you sick [ __ ] you're supposed to
look at a thumbnail jackoff and move on
dude what's wrong with you
like these are like you know I know her
first and last name I follow on
Instagram I was like you have a sickness
birla like if you ask me the name of a
porn star I know like classic people
right like jenna jameson and [ __ ]
tera patrick yeah beyond that you got me
and then ron jeremy for his [ __ ]
14-inch dick like you know like there's
the new ones you're sick [ __ ] deplorable
human being you trash back but yeah man
like you know you just uh you watch clip
after clip off to be good that's that's
the world we live in now it's like more
and more and more and more and more and
more and more and more yeah instead of
like finding quality and really enjoying
something of quality for for all the
thought and energy that was put into
that you know and I don't think film is
so romanticized nowadays to that I think
the the sad part about things that I
don't understand I see us a lot in
comments and I see this a lot in kids
who apply for work and drop and they
want to work with me they go like oh
yeah like I love blah blah blah the
first thing I asked to is like top three
favorite directors four favorite films
what are they yeah nothing and I'm like
then why are we having this conversation
yeah like well why do you want to go to
film you don't watch film yeah are you
talking about dude not even for me it's
like I like I I thought I didn't
watching that film I'm like you guys
don't watch any film yeah like so why do
you want to be a director then why do
you what do you want to go in the film
why do you want to write you don't even
have a favorite writer you don't have a
favorite director you don't know
anything about the craft that you want
to be a part of that's like oh I just
got to watch a few things and know if it
was that [ __ ] easy everybody would do
it
yeah you know you you just see the [ __ ]
from the outside you don't know the type
of like like theater training how much
acting class is like when all these
people go into like their background
they like well I don't need to go to
traditional whatever writing schools
because I could just see what I like in
a film and just do it there's a system
to this [ __ ] that helps I was like I
really wish that
was the case for a lot of people but
there's a few people that can do it
right but not everybody and unless
you're that special person why not do
the extra work and try that out it's a
lifelong endeavor man yeah you know it's
it's like anything you know like it it
just takes so much it just takes a lot
of time also for you to get good to
marinate you know I'm like I'm I'm just
starting out man as a director and I
start has so much [ __ ] to learn like you
know and and you know how much film I
watch like a little [ __ ] in a
psychopath food but I watch a lot of
film but even then I'm like compared to
compared a lot of other people that I
know
hmm I'm nothing yeah I'm still like just
scheming you know just very very
scratching the surface like people that
I know my film knowledge is like that
and and they've really sat with some of
these like a lot of these films and
analyzed it and you know and I think
that's the other thing is um critical
thinking yeah you know just like well if
you want to be a director a writer like
just think critically about it like you
know so what do you think first of all
ask yourself the question why why do you
want to do it in what is a purpose and
the secondly like okay then what do you
need to do and if you if you haven't
even like so this one actor told me one
time you know and he's a veteran I he's
been on Ralph forever and I was like and
I was a kid I was like hey man so I want
to get better at acting and we were at
this like you know and I wasn't a nobody
like we were at this signing event thing
and and I was like yeah you know I want
to do that and he's like okay how many
um Paul how many Paul Newman
performances have you seen well I've
seen color money I seen you know Cool
Hand Luke he's like what else I mean not
much out of that like what Jake Lemmon
Brando you know all these like greats
and I was like well you know I seen a
few he's like dude he was like dude why
you why like if you haven't even done
that work like why you asked me this
[ __ ] I'm like well what do you mean he's
like okay if you were
say Kobe do you think Kobe doesn't know
like all the stats all the [ __ ] study
footage of all the greats and like has
done everything he can
he studied everyone who comes before
them if you were [ __ ] in baseball
like [ __ ] and say you're like whoever
it is like Darryl Strawberry or whatever
it is like you would study all the
grades from Babe Ruth on like everybody
because you got to know where you came
from to know where you got to go and if
you haven't done even that minutes like
the bear bear bear bear bear minimum
what is what he was telling me and it
was a wake-up call it was like oh [ __ ]
you're right you doing stand-up dude you
have to have studied all the grades you
know like all the greats and understand
the mechanics of what why their jokes
work and their style of storytelling and
all that stuff if you didn't if you
didn't go through and really studied it
and figure out what makes them tick how
to expect how do you expect to innovate
on it you know like that's the hard part
for people to really listen to and
understand because people take this type
of advice sometimes and they think that
you're sitting on their dreams it's like
that's not nobody sitting there like
well why do I have to do that it's not
that you have to [ __ ] yeah but but don't
be disappointed when it doesn't when it
doesn't work out the way you think it's
gonna work out yeah and then then
there's this whole thing where they
can't point their fingers this way that
the pointed outwards they go it's
because I'm Asian it's because I'm this
and that and that's why there's like
certain people in this space that they
know that I don't like them because I'm
very vocal about it obviously right and
like I even had a conversation recently
with one of my friends and it was like
they were like oh yeah one of the guys
that I vocally dislike and we should
name you should name that I wish I
really I would but everybody's telling
me not to so like I'm like okay because
it doesn't help yeah yeah cool I
understand I'm learning to be more civil
but I feel like it's entertaining yeah
and they're like okay well they asked
them like specifically why I don't like
them he was like I don't know why he
doesn't like me and I was like was
because I [ __ ] like that you expect the
world to be given to you
yeah and it's those type of
conversations what I dislike about
people the most is were they they blame
everything on
they say it's because I'm Asian why
people don't like me ya know
Asian people also don't like you dude
yeah so it's not nothing because of your
ethnicity dude it's because of you and
you don't want to take that
responsibility yeah I'm not getting
these opportunities because I'm Asian
don't place it put it on our culture
vultures fine yeah [ __ ] with us they
don't [ __ ] with you so don't don't drag
us down just so you can lift yourself up
tear down I'm so curious who this is
that [ __ ] [ __ ] hell I just you
know and they're not I don't think
they're bad human being I am but they're
just they're just too phony about their
[ __ ] and I don't really vibe with that
yeah like like if whatever like I don't
really think twice about them yeah but
the fact that they oh they always have
to bring me up in some type of cover
that don't worry if I don't like you
just I just don't like you you [ __ ]
move on yes I'm just one person also
this person's going around telling
everybody oh yeah you don't like me and
then now it like because I'm an [ __ ]
like I specifically I'm like well
because it bothers them I just do it
more now like okay damn it David like be
nicer which I was trying to do this year
it's not happening so haha but you know
I just I just don't like that it's like
do you here's a great advice that you
gave to one of our friends right you
asked him I remember you told him you
said you know you know he wasn't booking
a lot of rules right and you you know he
I told you to talk to him and you talked
to him and you said something very very
profound and very simple he goes well
with these roles like why do you think
you're not booking them and you go he
goes well you know do you think you're
good in it he goes I think I'm ready he
goes and you told him he was like well
if I put you next to your favorite actor
who's your favorite actor and I think he
said like Denzel at the time right and
you're like if do you think you can go
line from line with them and he goes no
and you're like well then get back to
work
yeah they get back to work yeah unless
if you are at some De Niro static yeah
you still you still should be training
yeah I don't understand when people are
like yeah I've done enough acting class
no you'll have and bro like even those
[ __ ] are doing plays in between
movies yeah Pacino is like does still
does plays mmm to Train and I'm like
well like and I'm guilty of it but like
why do you think that you are special in
a way that Pacino's doesn't think he's
special yeah that's crazy that's
delusion
yeah that's grand illusion
you know and that's goes for everything
like you know with me in directing dude
that's why I'm putting out that's why
I'm constantly directing that's why I'm
making felt like trying to make a film
like once a year once every two years
dude it's tough it's tiring I wish I
could take a year off but like if I
don't I'm not gonna get better yeah to
where I want to be you know and and they
were like oh you should be like you know
I'll tell you this after guk like people
were like don't just go direct something
else you have to direct something bigger
or you have to direct something studio
or whatever I always thought that phony
advice because I was like dude first of
all if I go do that they're not gonna
let me do what I want to do right mm-hmm
what I'm trying to do is I need to just
get out there and fail it's okay so like
when I was gonna go direct miss purple
everybody was like you sure you want to
cash out all your chips on that film
like you should cash it on some like I
was like cash on my chips I got no chips
man like I I'm I need to keep creating
for me to get better I'm not thinking of
this is like this one opportunity or
this like I got if I don't keep making
films I'm not gonna get better and I'm
not waiting six years between films like
other people do to to get back in the
Seabees you're not gonna what do you
think changes in six years you actually
get worse oh for sure you know and I'm
just like so I want to do it and like
everybody was really thought it was a
wrong decision maybe it was it wasn't
but a lot guk was a wrong decision too
though nobody even the film before that
man up that I did with keV like they
thought that wasn't but at the end a day
man like all of those films have got me
to where I am this reps yes all reps man
it's all reps and and you know mr.
purple man well if it was a bad decision
to make a film that got into competition
at Sundance you know I guess it was a
bad decision yeah you know I don't know
man but but beyond the results of it it
was the process that I was like no no
it's it's about the journey not not like
I don't look at it is in like do once
I'm done with a movie I'm done I'm like
I'm thinking about my next one yeah I'm
not resting on my laurels and being like
do you rarely ever hear about me talk
about
yeah I rather rarely ever talk with us
yeah because I'm I'm not like there's
stuff to learn from it and once awhile
go back and watch it because I can see
where I need to improve and where I was
and where I need to go but not too I
don't watch it to like Pat myself on the
back you know and I think that that is
the main difference it's the process for
me it's it's the road to where I want to
get to and and I might never get to
where I want to go but that's actually a
good thing you know you know but
everybody's so result-oriented and being
like when I get this when I do that when
I see one you know when this person like
does gives me this or like well it's
hard because like you're you're I mean I
don't think you should be the not the
outlier in this but the norm is that
most people do things for recognition
not because they love it and that's what
I'm finding out a lot yes like because
people will ask they go well why don't
you just post more on YouTube and do
these videos like it made you more money
well if I wanted to make more money I
would have done something way different
than entertaining yeah yeah you know
like money is money is the the ancillary
thing that came along with doing
something that I enjoyed right Google
didn't make as money no single Sam yeah
people are like yo men like you must be
[ __ ] taking off that [ __ ] and I'm
like again yeah really is that what you
think damn I wish yeah and then people
are like oh it's like what do you think
about us like to get guk was two years
ago but it feels like eons ago yeah like
it's it's hard to think about something
constantly like what is well okay cool
it happened like I moved on
yeah I mean like now it's time for me to
do something new but that was the thing
is I cook happen and afterwards like I
was like okay I gotta go make some money
I'm when did an ABC show yeah just like
you said like sometimes you gotta do
[ __ ] you don't want to do in order to
get to where you need to go yeah but
doing that show banked me financially so
I could make miss purple and take two
years off to like make miss purple in
this film about to make like you know
and like it's about the process I mean
I'm trying to get somewhere but like if
it requires me to do a few things I
don't want to do it then cool man but
like but even that ABC show you know
guess what I was doing when I was on
that set No hey what does that dude can
I touch that yeah
wait like why'd you put that light there
Oh where's that called that's that's
what I was doing like it but that's the
thing he's like everybody's like pouting
and whining about like wherever they're
adding to their life and why it's always
an opportunity man and like right now
you know I'm trying to get this film
made and and I'm putting out a film as
well you know and it's tough
everything's tough everything is tough
man
everything is so damn tough it's hard
because the the the biggest thing that
people ask consistently on this is to
they always they don't know how to be
passionate about something that they
love right because for you there's that
passion and a lot of people apparently
can't get to that point yeah because
they're more I think I'm more that norm
where I like things for a second but I
don't know how to dive in and something
a hundred percent yeah and it's because
like I don't know if I share that
singular passion right for you
whether it's directing or acting is
still within the art of film yeah that's
that's your thing yeah and I always tell
people amen you can be a jack of all
shits or you could be a jack of one
trade
yeah and for you to master one thing is
you'll never be able to do it within a
lifetime yeah so could you imagine how
hard it is to try to do six yeah right
everybody wants to do six though exactly
that's my problem
so like for you I think like that's why
you're able to progress because you
double down it's like okay if I'm gonna
be a director and this is what I want to
go and this is what this is where I want
to go and this is what I enjoy she did
one film you're doing another one and
then you're doing another one and
they're all different miss purple was a
way different film than guk was Yeah
right like number one it was like like
cinematography wife it was way different
yeah you know I mean the color was
beautiful yeah it was very a wong
kar-wai to me like yeah yeah wong
kar-wai but you know other influences
was like you know Corita
like corey ate his films and and a lot
of european films yeah but like then it
wasn't as dialogue heavy it was very
quiet yeah it was much more experienced
allanne introspective and it was
designed that way i really uh this is
type of film I want to make it's not as
commercial yeah but it's a it's supposed
to make you think and talk and and but
yeah and this this next film is a little
bit of both and but you know here's the
thing is like I can learn from anyways
so then I did a film you know after
after me
purple after I shot miss purple when I
was doing post mm-hmm I'm his purple
Wayne Wang the director of Joy Luck Club
and smoke and he's like oh oh gee like
he's one of the two og independent
filmmakers he made a film called Chan is
missing for like four or five thousand
dollars it's a film that's very
respected amongst like cinephiles and
and uh you know his his film smoke with
Harvey Keitel is amazing and you know he
this guy is he's lived a life of film
and and he called me up he's like hey
you know I want to under this film do
you want to do you want to be the lead
in it and everything I was like what's
about well it's about you know a guy
who's cooking a final meal for his mom
who's standing of cancer I was like huh
that's funny because I just made a film
about a parent who's dying as well I was
like are you okay with that because I
just want I just want to be transparent
that I just did a film about the same
thing as I get he was not worried at all
yeah he's like nah man and I was like
[ __ ] I should go and see how this guy
does this yeah take on this subject and
I went on that set and I didn't see it
as like he didn't see it as threatening
he like he it was all gravy and I
learned so much from him and like you
know at the end of the day the whole
experience was so nourishing to me
because I was like [ __ ] man there's
there's so many different ways to do
this and this dude who's like older now
and basically retired he says he's
retired but he keeps making films yeah
but he loves it so much Lee retired yeah
yeah yeah but he loves film so much that
like you know he wanted to make this
thing anyone and make it out of the
system kind of like ant-man it's the
best it's a but I was in the middle of
post I was like I shouldn't leave you
know I'm trying to fight the Sundance
deadline I was like no no this
experience probably is gonna give me
more than what I think and it's going to
Toronto it's going to Toronto
International Film Festival I'm like
well but man like I'm doing I'm you know
just because like I'm trying to learn
from everywhere I'm not just trying to
like it that's the thing I think you're
talking about with these kids is like
they don't want to learn from you they
come to do an internship for you but
they don't really want to learn from you
they just want to get the cred and they
just want to say they worked with you
probably they don't actually are cure
about your process or like or what
drives you or the things that matter to
you in life and like looking for some
mentorship you know I mean it's hard cuz
like I in in and I try to explain
sometimes and sometimes I'm nice enough
where I'll respond back where I'm just
like like what why like I'm always
wondering why yeah and I was like
they're like cause cuz you know I had I
just had an email just this the email
was nice and I always asked him to I was
like well why'd you come to me if you
want to do film yeah they're like well
it's because this is it like I saw you
on Utah's like I'm not film you're not
you're coming to the wrong person so you
already started off bad
I'm not film yeah you need to go intern
and work for somebody else yeah like
you're you're already I was like either
you're doing this because you either
want to be around me and then you know
I've helped you out in your life which
great I love that [ __ ] but it would be a
disservice of me for me to take your
free work and I don't teach you anything
yeah I can't teach you anything I'm
learning right now yeah so I'm still a
student student student and then you're
trying to learn from me I got nothing to
give you
yeah like go you need to work on set you
need to go get that type of experience
cuz that's the experience that I'm
getting right now yeah so it's it's
weird it's like I think sometimes people
just look for the thing that's familiar
and it's the easier way out yeah it's
not the right choice it's not yeah you
know there's no way that I can help you
out about all this like spis
like because this person specifically
must be a director mm-hmm wrong person
bro director dude nah dude I'm a [ __ ]
comic like I don't I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing
yeah you know other than that like right
now I'm just trying to write like I'm
learning how to write right now yeah I
can't help you out
you know yeah so its breath yeah man I
don't know you know I think um find
people who you know if we're if if this
podcast is more about like telling young
people about what may be a good advice
like find somebody you admire man you
know and try to figure out what makes
him tick like you know if he came to you
and said listen I'm trying to be a
director but I just like your philosophy
of laia and the way you roll and like
and and I vibe with your you're the
you're your perspective on on the world
I think you would have reacted
differently oh for sure you know and you
could have said you know as a director
like I'm looking for different
perspectives I have shaped my view on
the world
how can you how could I said no how can
you say no to that but like ah yeah you
know and I don't when I worked with
Wayne man I came I came with you know
humbly and I I I could be like I could
go there and be like oh yeah I [ __ ]
directed a few films too and you know
what like I go in there being like
completely open minded and like whatever
you want also treating him like the
director I was like you're the director
I'm here too I'm here to service you you
know but [ __ ] dude like he was something
small like on this indie film that I'm
on like like being around lamorne right
now like watching him work like like
it's improv and everything and how great
he is on set I'm just like sitting he
doesn't know this but I'm looking at him
like I'm lying and why some [ __ ]
notes on this [ __ ] yeah I mean I'm like
oh [ __ ] there is like a like this huge
gap at difference between being hip like
here in [ __ ] here well he just had so
many hours yeah I just had some reps are
there you know number one he takes
acting classes he's trained and then you
could see those huge differences and
that's why I like you know people well
you don't take any acting classes and
then you guys thought it doesn't mean
I'm good yeah I mean I'm good at what I
do yeah you know what I mean yeah but
you can't compare me to somebody who's
like classically trained that's
continuing to grow and they put all
their chips into acting to me yeah cuz
that's from I'm here and they're right
here
lamorne is it good but lamorne has a
good attitude about it all yeah you know
I remember like I did episode new girl
with him right and and tell him I said
what up by the way he's a good dude but
like when I was chilling with um once
said just chill man yeah he's a nice
dude he's a chill ass dude it wasn't
like I'm [ __ ] serious regular
whatever like get the [ __ ] away from me
it was like we and we you know we we
know some mutual people but like just a
chill ass like really stand-up dude and
look in and and it's a reason why people
love to work with him yeah you know I
would love to work with him or him
because he's just like he's a real dude
he's not like trying to be celebrity
kind of like you know flex his you know
slow flex his status or nothing like
he's just chill as [ __ ] yeah this is
really great to be around there's other
guy named Matt McGregor he's on the show
how to get away with murder that's
[ __ ] awesome - my nose work it's work
I mean lamorne some like l'amour he just
doesn't work yeah it just doesn't work
in he's he's a professional you know and
I think that's the other difference is
like you know understanding what it
means to be a professional yeah like not
talking about something like hobbyist
yeah you know actually you know
understanding what the job entails and
the type of prep and and you know the
type of like you know and then you got
people who kind of phone it in and they
can they sort of rest on their laurels
and all that stuff but that's why they
progressing or they're not happy in life
and they don't find any joy in their
work you know anymore you know like you
see it these actors that have been
around forever and they're just they're
famous whatever and you just see one
said I'm like that's it yeah no wonder
you so unhappy with your life you want
to be get written off the show and blah
blah blah blah blah because you don't
enjoy what you're doing you don't enjoy
what you're doing anymore and like you
just why are you even here
mm-hmm why even here but someone like
lamorne he's like no I could see him
pushing man yeah and uh you know from
where he came from - I don't you talk to
him about like yeah anyway like yeah I
mean I think uh you can learn from all
that [ __ ] I'm sure you're learning a
shitload on the set oh for sure a lot
yeah I'm just like just watching them
work is pretty awesome just yeah it's
just like oh [ __ ] you know because like
acting is one of those like ancillary
passions that I had right yes unless I
dive all in it's not gonna get any
better and I understand this like I
that's why I get pic roles where I can
kill what I can do yeah you know if it
takes me out of something that I don't
normally do it's gonna be a rough family
yeah cuz then I have to sit I gotta go
get an acting coach I got to sit work
with them for like months and then I'll
be able to come in but you know look I
feel like with him or even you if you
get something within like four or five
days
you'll be able to do it yeah me if it's
not something that I'm already used to
and this role was kind of like tailored
towards me so like cool I can do this so
I got I got the script like literally
two days before they were shooting like
well I could do this thank God but it
was like this character like okay well
this character's he's a father and then
the
the mother died recently and you also
come yeah and like well I'm have to pass
on this cuz I will not be able to do
this yeah you know it's hard yeah it's a
craft to it yeah absolutely
but um you know I mean it's a fun
journey man it's really it's it's one of
the hardest endeavors that I've it is
the hardest endeavor that I've taken on
in my life and but I am still here you
know I'm like you know I'm 38 now so if
I started 20 like that's 18 years and
I'm still in it
yeah I'm still like I'm still feel like
I'm a baby a novice like I think that's
good yeah you know and and I hope to be
like Wayne and still like you know
hello old still like excited and like
dude we were on set and we do something
like a take that was awesome and we
weren't expecting whatever and between
takes we'd like giving each other
high-fives and [ __ ] no dude that's
awesome makes me happy yeah makes him
happy made me happy I'm just like man
this is awesome that that I couldn't
believe how joyful he still was and not
jaded he was and how he take everything
personal too you know like there's
things that like you know when people
don't like the film whatever like it
really gets him down so to see it still
affect him and that would do it if I was
him I'd be like [ __ ] you you know I did
this this at this is this and like I
don't give a [ __ ] what you think he does
and I think that's what keeps him alive
and like really still kickin and all
that um you know I was like when you
gonna write me like when we gonna work
together again like when you gonna write
me a new thing he's like I'm working on
it I'm like cool I'll do what I've liked
even if he doesn't pay me I'll be there
no there's not about the money at all
yeah it's just it's a conversation of
just passion and you know notoriety but
yeah I think working for passion can
keep you going for a very very long time
yeah working for just notoriety that
should is fleeting dude like that should
disappear so yeah so [ __ ] fast well I
think you know what I realized in the
last few years is the thing that helps
me
continue to do what I do is if it's not
for myself you know if there's a purpose
a bigger sort of reason I'm doing it
that is beyond my own borders you know
and like having it you know like I have
a kid and everything and and that
introspection that's happened after
having the kid like it really has
changed how I look at the world and how
I move in the things I want to take on
and but the biggest thing is like I have
a purpose I have a purpose in this world
for what I do and why I'm doing it so it
allows me in the worst of times to be
like well boohoo yeah me but you still
have to do this for this group of people
and you have to do it to make you know
at least your corner of the world a
little bit brighter and that to me is is
worthwhile yeah you know um yeah so like
that really keeps me going rather than
any of the ancillary [ __ ] you know
you know yeah cool well that's an hour
in that was quick and then we're good
now yeah
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the of genius brain we got justin chon
in here remember to support miss purple
when it comes out
September 6 miss purple comes out at the
new word in Santa Monica the next
weekend it'll be at Landmark Theaters in
New York City and will expand in LA and
then after that it's gonna be in most
major cities but your money where your
mouth is you stupid [ __ ] about that
huh yeah but you guys can find us on
Spotify iTunes any type of podcast audio
thing make sure you guys give us that
five star and we'll see you guys again
remember we upload every Thursdays and
Sundays and I will see y'all next time
yes smelly smelly [ __ ] peace pace